This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）为你带来的《艰难学习》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个节目专注于黑人男性的生活经历，进行在其他任何地方都觉得不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士一起交流。有多少男人背负着一身铠甲？它向世界释放出信号，表明你不是好惹的。这并不意味着你必须这么做，收听《艰难学习》。
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方搜索并收听。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你最终就会成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“2%”。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜们。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
收听《相信闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》（The Girlfriends），在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。在《回顾往昔》（Look Back at It）播客中。从1979年开始，那对我的意义重大。84年对我来说意义非凡。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners.
与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方搜索并收听《回顾往昔》。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），在这个播客中，我们探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活改变和过渡，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众，老听众。
wherever you are in the world, it is great to have you here back for another episode. Today, we are talking about something I think all of us have struggled with at some point in our lives, and that is why we are so hard on ourselves, like all the time. It feels like this is the generation of self-criticism. As humans, and I think particularly in our 20s, we're often our harshest critics. We tirelessly scrutinize every little decision, every action, every outcome in our lives. Why am I such a failure? Why did I say that? Why don't I look like them? I must be doing something wrong. And we constantly strive for perfection, expecting ourselves to reach these impossible standards that we've never really held for anyone else in our lives. But I think it's really interesting
无论你身在世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能回来收听又一期节目。今天，我们要讨论的是我认为我们所有人在生命中的某个时刻都曾苦恼过的问题，那就是为什么我们对自己总是那么苛刻，感觉好像一整天都是如此。这似乎是一个自我批判的时代。作为人类，而且我认为特别是在我们20岁的时候，我们常常是自己最严厉的批判者。我们不知疲倦地审视着生活中的每一个小决定、每一个行动、每一个结果。为什么我这么失败？我为什么会说那样的话？为什么我长得不像他们？我一定是什么地方做错了。我们不断地追求完美，期望自己达到那些我们从未对生活中的任何人要求过的、不可能达到的标准。但我认为这真的很有趣，
to examine why we put ourselves through this. What kind of drives this inner critic and this relentless pursuit of being flawless or perfect? The other irony of self-criticism that I find really fascinating, but also a bit disturbing or interesting, is that we speak to ourselves in a way that we would never dream of doing so to others. So why do we find it so hard to give ourselves the same grace, the same love, the same forgiveness, that we give people like our family, like our friends, like our partners. So today, we are going to peel back the layers of our inner critic and examine some of the evolutionary, biological, social roots of why we are so hard on ourselves. A lot of the theory says that it may actually come down to survival,
去审视我们为什么要经历这一切。是什么在驱动着这个内心的批判者，以及对完美或无瑕的这种不懈追求？自我批判的另一个讽刺之处，我发现它既非常迷人，又有点令人不安或有趣，那就是我们对自己说话的方式，是我们做梦也不会对别人做的事。那么，为什么我们觉得很难给予自己同样的宽容、同样的爱、同样的宽恕——就像我们对待家人、朋友、伴侣那样？所以今天，我们将剥开内心批判者的层层面纱，审视为什么我们对自己如此苛刻的进化、生物和社会根源。许多理论表明，这实际上可能归结于生存，
whereby we are overly self-critical to avoid stepping out of line or acting against a societal norm so that we can be accepted. Or in the case of things like self-deprecating humour, we use that to make ourselves feel and seem more agreeable or to mask our insecurities and protect ourselves. It all kind of comes down to, at the end of the day, our existence as so, social creatures and further to that, of course, our childhood. The words spoken to us as children, either by parents, by peers, by teachers, they become the words we speak to ourselves as adults. And a lot of that has to do with feeling like we need to earn love. We need to earn support, to earn the good things in our lives and be absolutely perfect or else we're not worth that kind of
因此我们过度自我批判，以避免出格或违背社会规范，从而获得接纳。或者在像自嘲式幽默这样的情况下，我们用它来让自己感觉和显得更好接近，或者掩饰我们的不安全感并保护自己。归根结底，这一切都归结于我们作为社会生物的本质，除此之外，当然还有我们的童年。小时候对我们说的话，无论是父母、同龄人还是老师说的，都成为了我们成年后对自己说的话。这很大程度上与觉得我们需要赢得爱有关。我们需要赢得支持，赢得生活中的美好事物，并且必须绝对完美，否则我们就配不上那种
treatment. So let's discuss. We're going to talk about the origins of this nasty inner critic, but also how we can silence that inner voice. This episode, it's not about dwelling in the negativity. It's about gaining awareness, embracing vulnerability, and ultimately, I think, finding compassion for ourselves amidst all of our imperfections. I also really want to deep dive into some pretty, I would say, innovative, new therapeutic practices that have come about recently, including radical self-compassion and cognitive diffusion. These are both amazing practices and skills that can help us kind of silence that little mean voice in our head. I'm really keen for this episode. I hope you are too. Also a quick reminder that if you like my content and want to support me further,
对待。所以我们来讨论一下。我们要讨论这个讨厌的内心批判者的起源，以及我们如何能够让那个内心的声音安静下来。这一集不是关于沉溺于消极情绪。而是关于获得觉醒，拥抱脆弱，归根结底，我认为是在所有的不完美中学会对自己保持同情。我还想深入探讨一些相当具有创新性的、最近出现的新治疗实践，包括激进的自我同情和认知解离。这些都是了不起的实践和技巧，可以帮助我们让我们脑海中那个尖酸刻薄的小声音安静下来。我非常期待这一集。希望你也是。另外温馨提醒一下，如果你喜欢我的内容并想进一步支持我，
to please subscribe to my Patreon. It is just me here writing, producing, recording, putting out this podcast every week. And it's a lot of work. So I do really appreciate any support that you can throw my way. So without further ado, let's get into the psychology behind why we are so hard on ourselves. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
请订阅我的Patreon。这里只有我一个人在每周写作、制作、录制、发布这个播客。这需要很多工作。所以我真的很感激你能给予的任何支持。废话不多说，让我们进入为什么我们对自己如此苛刻背后的心理学。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。
On my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你最终就会还给世界一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是“TWO%”。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上拍了拍小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out. on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down,
或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以去寻找答案。在《回顾往昔》播客中。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but yeah, yeah, yeah.
并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近的一集，马克·拉蒙特·希尔大谈80年代的可卡因。需要澄清的是，84年对我意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊聊可卡因，但好吧，好吧，好吧。
But just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
但为了让你们知道我的意思。马克，这是我们第二期讨论可卡因了。所以我开始看出这里有一条主线。我们现在还讨论了艾滋病。谢谢你把话说完。我认为没有比这更重要的年份了，对于黑人来说。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and, conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking.
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。收听《回顾往昔》，在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难学习》，我是主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的有，
Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们在追求某样东西时，我们太陷入追逐本身，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于赢和输。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions. bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地做一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《艰难学习》中，我们将就疗愈、成长、父职、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio App。搜索《艰难学习》并立即收听。
In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
2023年，前《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Echard）发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了长达数年的法律战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试，对吗？我只篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批网络侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格（Greg）、一个女同性恋者，以及迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的天呐。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I think I've recently become quite cognizant of the fact that for the longest time, maybe the majority of my life, I have always been my own worst critic, the loudest voice in my head, constantly drowning out all the positive things in my life with negative predictions and self-doubt, kind of honing that spotlight in on everything that I'm doing wrong and ignoring all the good things. It even got to the point where I was becoming self-critical. about how much I was self-critical. I would have these thoughts about how I was so stupid or had messed up and then an even louder voice would jump in and scold me for being like that. And neither of these voices was particularly kind or helpful.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻：劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这还没结束。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。我想我最近清楚地意识到这样一个事实：在很长的一段时间里，也许是我生命中的大部分时间里，我一直都是自己最严厉的批评者，是我脑海中最响亮的声音，不断用消极的预测和自我怀疑淹没我生活中的所有积极事物，将聚光灯对准我所做错的一切，而忽略了所有美好的事物。甚至到了后来，我开始对自己进行了自我批判，
So I've also become really fascinated with the why. As someone who is obviously really interested in psychology, it can be really hard to not seek an explanation for these kinds of of behaviors and know that there is possibly a very logical, scientific, robust underpinning or kind of cause. I think it also minimizes, I think, some of the shame and the personal blame that often accompanies self-criticism. And in this instance, there are so many explanations that explain why we are so hard on ourselves. So self-criticism, it's this tendency to evaluate ourselves extremely harshly and to scrutinize our actions, our performance, our behavior, our body, our relationship, almost every aspect of our lives. It's distinct from self-awareness and the occasional
关于我有多少自我批判。我会有这些想法，觉得自己太蠢了或者把事情搞砸了，然后一个更响亮的声音会跳出来责备我。而这两个声音都不是特别友善或有帮助。所以我也对“为什么”产生了浓厚的兴趣。作为一个人对心理学非常感兴趣的人，很难不去寻找这些行为的解释，并且知道可能存在一个非常合乎逻辑、科学、强有力的基础或某种原因。我认为这也减少了一些伴随自我批判而来的羞耻感和个人指责。在这种情况下，有太多的解释可以说明为什么我们对自己如此苛刻。因此，自我批判是一种极度严苛地评估自己，并审视我们的行动、表现、行为、身体、关系，几乎是我们生活中方方面面的倾向。它不同于自我意识和偶尔的
self-policing in that it's a very automatic self-criticism, self-blame, it often feels like it's beyond our control. And our default in any situation, our default mental pattern is to actively blame ourselves and find our faults rather than see a situation objectively. Be it's excessively negative and maladaptive. It goes against our best interests and it actually undermines some of that helpful, productive behavior and coping mechanisms because this voice is so unnecessarily cruel. See is that we believe it. Unlike, I think, the occasional bad thought about others that we can dismiss or call ourselves out for, when we are hard on ourselves, the only person who can validate that belief is us. And so we tend to believe these
自我审视，因为它是一种非常自动化的自我批判、自我责备，通常感觉超出了我们的控制。我们在任何情况下的默认反应，我们的默认心理模式是主动责备自己并找出我们的缺点，而不是客观看待情况。这是过度消极且适应不良的。它违背了我们的最大利益，实际上削弱了一些有帮助的、富有成效的行为和应对机制，因为这个声音实在是太不必要的残酷了。原因是我们相信了它。不像偶尔对别人产生不好的想法，我们可以将其摒弃或反省，但当我们对自己苛刻时，唯一能证实这种信念的人就是我们自己。因此，我们倾向于相信这些
negative thoughts. We tend to really take them on board because the voice, the opinion that is with us, the most in our lives is our own. So it's the one that we trust the most as well. And finally, D, it negatively impacts our lives. We may find ourselves skipping social events or going out, not putting ourselves out there, dating people who treat us poorly, or ruminating on our failures to a point where we can't move on and we do become stuck in that moment and stuck in that thought spiral. All of these things, I think, really detract from the now, but also from our reality. And they make it incredibly hard to be gentle and to have a kind mind and a really soft internal space for us to thrive. All of this stems from what we call in pop psychology the inner critic, this subpersonality,
消极的想法。我们倾向于真正地接受它们，因为在我们生活中陪伴我们最多的声音、观点就是我们自己的声音。所以这也是我们最信任的声音。最后D，它对我们的生活产生了负面影响。我们可能会发现自己逃避社交活动或外出，不敢展现自己，与那些对我们不好的人约会，或者沉溺于我们的失败中，以至于无法前进，被困在那一刻和那种思想的漩涡中。我认为，所有这些事情都在很大程度上削弱了当下，也削弱了我们的现实。它们使得我们很难对温柔以待，很难拥有一个善良的心灵和真正柔软的内心空间来让我们蓬勃发展。这一切都源于我们在大众心理学中所说的内心批判者，这个次人格，
this almost separate unconscious entity that judges and demeans us. The inner critic is, the inner is the voice in our head telling us that we are worthless or shaming us. And it's been theorized that it's actually a manifestation of our ego. More specifically, what Freud called our super ego. So this super ego is something that we all kind of develop in early childhood. And it's that part of us that internalizes all the things that society wants us to do, or the lessons from our parents or the scolding, and it automatically senses our behavior. It's this kind of unconscious mechanism for regulating our actions, and that's basically where the inner critic comes from. It's natural to have this impulse control, right?
这个几乎是独立的无意识实体，一直在评判和贬低我们。内心批判者就是，内心就是我们脑海中的声音，告诉我们一文不值或羞辱我们。理论上认为这实际上是我们的自我（ego）的一种表现。更具体地说，就是弗洛伊德所说的超我（super ego）。所以这个超我，是我们每个人在童年早期发展出来的一部分，它是我们体内内化了社会希望我们做的一切事情的部分，或者是来自父母的教训或责骂，它会自动感知我们的行为。这是一种调节我们行动的无意识机制，这基本上就是内心批判者产生的地方。拥有这种冲动控制是自然的，对吧？
To have our ego override some of those extreme impulses, otherwise our society would kind of fall into anarchy. But when that inner critic is given too much control. Instead of moderating certain behaviors, it absolutely paralyzes us. And I think one of the major ironies of self-criticism is that whilst we are constantly putting ourselves down and very carefully self-montering every little behaviour for some perceived fault, we rarely level that same amount or severity of criticism against others. We have no problem celebrating our friends, accepting their failures, overlooking small things, hyping them up. But we cannot treat ourselves in the same way. There's actually a very rational scientific explanation behind why this may be.
让我们的自我压制某些极端的冲动，否则我们的社会就会陷入无政府状态。但是当这个内心批判者被赋予了太多的控制权。它不但没有适度调整某些行为，反而让我们彻底瘫痪了。我认为自我批判的主要讽刺之处之一是，虽然我们不断贬低自己，并且非常仔细地自我监控每一个小行为以找出所谓的过错，但我们很少对别人施加同样数量或严重程度的批评。我们毫无困难地庆祝我们的朋友，接受他们的失败，忽视小事情，为他们加油打气。但我们却无法以同样的方式对待自己。这背后其实有一个非常理性的科学解释。
Some researchers have proposed that we actually use different areas of our brain for judging others and judging ourselves because we are more attuned to our own behaviour for survival, a lot less than the behaviour of others. In one study conducted in the US, they actually examined this and what they did was they got participants to respond to a series of situations either from a place of self-criticism or suicide. self reassurance. For example, they may have been told that they just received a rejection letter for a job and they were instructed to either speak kindly to themselves or to self-criticize. Whilst they were doing this, they had them hooked up to an fMRI machine. This basically examines where blood is kind of flowing in the brain and the logic is that when an area of the brain is active, it needs more blood. So therefore, we can link the current behavior with the specific cortex or region. And the results revealed this very significant
一些研究人员提出，我们实际上用大脑的不同区域来评判别人和评判自己，因为为了生存，我们对自身行为的关注度要远远低于对他人行为的关注度。在美国进行的一项研究中，他们实际上检验了这一点，他们的做法是让参与者对一系列情境做出回应，这些情境要么出于自我批判，要么出于自我安慰。例如，他们可能被告知他们刚刚收到了一封工作拒绝信，并被指示要么对自己说友善的话，要么进行自我批判。在他们这样做的同时，他们被连接到fMRI（功能性磁共振成像）机器上。这基本上检查了血液在大脑中的流动情况，其逻辑是当大脑的一个区域处于活动状态时，它需要更多的血液。因此，我们可以将当前的行为与特定的皮层或区域联系起来。结果显示出了非常显着的
association between self-criticism and the prefrontal cortex, the part of our brain that is involved in regulating our thoughts and our emotions, but also in error detection and resolution, as well as behavioral response inhibition, preventing us from doing things that are life-threatening or maybe embarrassing. And what this essentially concluded is that self-criticism, as demeaning and awful as it is, may actually have an evolutionary role in keeping us safe from things like dangerous, repetitive behaviors and possibly life-threatening errors. However, when it gets out of control, the opposite is also true. That's just one kind of biological possibility amongst many. The other one has to do with temperament and personality.
自我批判与前额叶皮层（我们大脑中参与调节思想和情绪的部分，同时也参与错误检测和解决，以及行为反应抑制，防止我们做一些危及生命或令人尴尬的事情的部分）之间的关联。这基本上得出的结论是，自我批判虽然听起来贬低且糟糕，但在保护我们免受危险、重复行为以及可能危及生命的错误的侵害方面，实际上可能发挥着某种进化的作用。然而，当它失控时，情况正好相反。这只是众多生物学可能性中的一种。另一种则与气质和性格有关。
The leading theory around why we are so hard on ourselves is that self-criticism is a negative personality trait that we all innately possess. But this trait exists on a spectrum or a continuum. And those of us who possess this very loud inner critic, are measuring higher on self-criticism as a personality trait. Some of that comes from our temperament, maybe our DNA, you know, the mystery of where personality comes from, it's still a bit of a black box in psychology.
关于为什么我们对自己如此苛刻的主导理论是，自我批判是我们天生都具有的一种消极性格特征。但这个特征存在于一个光谱或连续体上。我们当中那些拥有非常响亮的内心批判者的人，在自我批判这一性格特征上的得分更高。其中一部分源于我们的气质，也许还有我们的DNA，你知道，性格来源的秘密在心理学中仍然是一个有点神秘的黑匣子。
But we do know that personality traits like self-criticism are a combination of nature, that being our genetics, and nurture, how we were raised. And that really leads into what I think is one of the biggest, determining factors and reasons why some of us are so deeply self-critical. Adverse childhood experiences and childhood upbringing. We know so much more now about the kind of environment, the kind of reassurance and love that children need to grow, especially compared to a few generations ago. Studies have continuously shown across so many different areas that
但我们确实知道，像自我批判这样的性格特征是先天（也就是我们的基因）和后天（我们的养育方式）的结合。这确实引出了我认为是最大的决定因素和原因之一，为什么我们有些人会有如此深刻的自我批判。不良的童年经历和童年养育方式。与几代人之前相比，我们现在对儿童成长所需的环境、保证和爱有了更多的了解。各项研究在许多不同领域不断表明，
persistent parental criticism being constantly put down, even childhood bullying, instills what we would call a negative self-image and feelings of inherent inadequacy that continue into childhood. I think it used to be a very common belief that excessive criticism made a child stronger. And we know now that it doesn't, it just doesn't. And the reason some of us are so hard on ourselves, likely originating. from those early relationships with caregivers and also with peers. So as children, we really internalize the words spoken to us, the language used against us, the treatment and how we incorporate those things as truth, because we've never been told any differently. Our only
长期的父母批判、不断被贬低、甚至童年时期的欺凌，都会灌输我们所说的消极自我形象和固有的不安全感，这些感觉会延续到童年。我认为过去人们普遍认为过度的批判会使孩子变得更坚强。但我们现在知道事实并非如此，根本不是这样。我们有些人之所以对自己如此苛刻，很可能是起源于
source of self-esteem is those around us. And when we're told that we're just not that smart, that we're ugly, that we're embarrassing, that we're worthless, these things become part of our belief system and part of our self-concept. Those early years are just so formative because it's during that time that our brains are laying those important neural pathways, they're understanding our relationship to others, and we really need the validation of our caregivers. We need a loving environment to feel good about ourselves. Or when we don't receive that, the consequences are lifelong.
与照顾者以及同龄人的早期关系。因此，作为孩子，我们真正内化了对我们说的话，针对我们的语言，受到的对待以及我们如何将这些东西作为真相内化，因为我们从来没有被告知过不同的情况。我们唯一的
And it's not just this kind of emotional neglect or verbal scolding that's influential. When we face really high expectations from our family, you know the need for perfect grades to do a few sports, play a couple of musical instruments to be excellent at all of them, our standards for ourselves are incredibly out of proportion to what we're sustainably able to accomplish. But yet our sense of self has been hijacked for this need. for approval and to be perfect, and we begin to internalize these expectations and self-police through excessive criticism. It's also influenced by how our parents or caregivers treat praise and love. In psychology, there is this important distinction between conditional and unconditional
自尊来源就是周围的人。当我们被告知我们不够聪明，我们很丑，我们很尴尬，我们一文不值时，这些事情就成为了我们的信念系统和自我概念的一部分。那些早期的岁月是如此具有形成性，因为正是在这段时间里，我们的大脑正在铺设那些重要的神经通路，它们在理解我们与他人的关系，我们真的需要照顾者的肯定。我们需要一个充满爱的环境来对自己感觉良好。当我们没有得到时，后果将是终身的。
positive regard. So conditional positive regard means only giving someone love, giving them support, praise, warmth when they meet certain expectations or a set of conditions. Love is conditional on our ability to meet some standard. It's not freely given. In contrast, we have unconditional positive regard, and that means loving someone supporting them regardless of whether they meet our expectations. We can see why conditional positive regard might be especially harmful as a child and also contribute to that self-criticism later in adulthood.
而且不仅仅是这种情感忽视或言语责骂具有影响力。当我们面临来自家庭的真正高期望时，你知道，需要完美的成绩来参加几项运动，演奏几种乐器并精通所有这些，我们为自己设定的标准与我们能够持续完成的能力完全不成比例。然而，我们的自我意识却被这种需求所劫持了。为了获得认可和追求完美，我们开始内化这些期望，并通过过度的批评来进行自我审视。它还受到我们的父母或照顾者如何对待表扬和爱的影响。在心理学中，条件性积极关注和无条件
If you learnt that love and warmth and support, all of which are basic human needs, were something to be earned, we become exceptionally good at blaming ourselves when we fail and we're found undeserving. This kind of attitude teaches us that it is our actions that caused us to be neglected, our actions that caused love and praise to be with us.
积极关注之间有一个重要的区别。因此，条件性积极关注意味着只有当一个人符合某些期望或一组条件时，才给予爱、支持、表扬和温暖。爱是以我们达到某种标准为条件的。它不是免费给予的。相比之下，我们有无条件积极关注，这意味着无论一个人是否符合我们的期望，都去爱他们、支持他们。我们可以看到为什么条件性积极关注对孩子来说可能特别有害，并也会导致成年后的自我批判。
held. Something about us is wrong. Something about us is bad. And we carry that with us for a long, long time. Like I always say the words spoken to us in childhood become the words we speak to ourselves in adulthood. And I found that over and over again to be true, especially when we dive further into the psychology behind negative self-talk. That inner critic we were speaking of before, that voice can often sound a lot like the voice of our parents or a judgmental friend, a bad ex-partner who put us down. Sometimes we don't realize how much we take on that apparent feedback of others, and they don't even need to be there or be saying those things for you to still think
如果你了解到爱、温暖和支持（这些都是人类的基本需求）是需要赢得的东西，那么当我们失败并发现自己不配得到时，我们就会变得非常善于责怪自己。这种态度教导我们，是我们的行为导致了我们被忽视，是我们的行为导致了爱和表扬被扣留。
about them, for you to still believe them. I remember back in, like, I don't know, a couple years ago, I was dating this guy right when I started this podcast. I think I was like six months into recording. And he said to me one day, he was like, your podcast is so generic. I don't think anyone is ever going to relate to it. And his voice runs through my head almost every time I publish an episode. Every time I do something different, every time I take a risk, no one's ever going to listen, no one's going to relate.
我们身上有什么地方不对劲。我们身上有什么地方是坏的。而且我们带着这种感觉很长时间、很长时间。就像我常说的，童年对我们说的话成为了我们成年后对自己说的话。我发现这被一次又一次地证实，特别是当我们更深入地探讨负面自我对话背后的心理学时。我们之前谈到的那个内心批判者，那个声音听起来往往很像我们父母的声音，或者一个爱评判的朋友，一个把我们贬低的前任伴侣。有时我们没有意识到我们在多大程度上吸收了别人明显的反馈，而他们甚至不需要在场或说那些话，你依然会去想它们，
But it's not his voice anymore, right? It's my voice now. because even though, you know, I tried to shake it off at the time, I loved that person. I unfortunately trusted his opinion and some part of me truly did believe him and took that so deeply and so to heart. And I think it was in the aftermath of that situation that I became particularly negative towards myself and quite self-deprecating. Self-deprecation is an element of this that I think is really important to discuss because
你依然会相信它们。我记得在，像，我不知道，几年前，我刚开始做这个播客的时候，我正在和一个男生约会。我想我大概录了六个月。有一天他对我说，你的播客太大众化了。我觉得不会有人能产生共鸣。每一次我发布新的一集，他的声音都在我的脑海中回响。每一次我做不同的事情，每一次我冒风险，没有人会听，没有人会产生共鸣。
it has so many nuanced hidden links to self-criticism that are rarely spoken about. I think a lot of us like to use self-deprecating jokes and humor at our expense, and we think it's funny, right? It keeps us humble. And it might seem fairly harmless to call ourselves stupid in front of our friends, to kind of downgrade our achievements. But really, that's actually just our inner critic, masking us as being humorous or being humble.
但那不再是他的声音了，对吧？现在是我的声音了。因为尽管，你知道，我当时试图摆脱它，我很爱那个人。我不幸地信任了他的意见，我内心某一部分确实相信了他，并把这话深深地记在心里。我想正是在那种情况之后，我对自己变得特别消极，并且相当自嘲。自嘲是其中的一个元素，我认为这非常重要，因为
at the end of the day, it's still a negative self-evaluation, even if you're joking. There's another explanation proposed by researchers that we adopt self-deprecation in an attempt to appear more modest and seem really agreeable, but I also find that we use this kind of language, these kinds of jokes to protect our self-esteem and our ego. If I already think that about myself, no one can use it against me. If I tear myself down first in a social situation, no one else can do it for me. It's an armor. It's a protective coping mechanism against the judgment of others. Sometimes I think we can even use it in some ways as a form of motivation. If you naturally have a negative self-perception, telling yourself you're
它有那么多微妙的、隐藏的与自我批判的联系，而这些很少被谈论。我想我们很多人喜欢拿自己开玩笑，进行自嘲式的幽默，我们觉得这很有趣，对吧？它让我们保持谦逊。在朋友面前说自己笨，降低自己的成就，这看起来似乎相当无害。但实际上，这其实只是我们的内心批判者，伪装成幽默或谦逊。
awful and that you're going to fail, for some people I think it can compel them to perform, to do better, to be better. That's not a particularly sustainable way of motivating ourselves, though, because when we fail, we just reinforce that belief system. And when we succeed, it's a fluke. That voice isn't going anywhere. That's the cycle, right? It's like drinking more alcohol and expecting it to help you become sober.
归根结底，这依然是一种消极的自我评价，即使你是在开玩笑。研究人员提出了另一种解释，即我们采取自嘲是为了显得更谦虚、更好相处，但我也发现我们使用这种语言，这种笑话来保护我们的自尊和自我。如果我已经在心里那样看自己了，就没人能用它来对付我了。如果我在社交场合首先贬低自己，别人就没法再这么做了。这是一套盔甲。这是一种针对他人评判的保护性应对机制。有时我想我们甚至可以以某种方式将其用作一种动机。如果你天生具有消极的自我认知，告诉自己你
Using self-criticism to push yourself or to eliminate your negative self-appraisal is not going to make you love yourself anymore. I want to discuss two other reasons why we are so hard on ourselves after this break, as well as some of the best ways to kind of break out of this habit, to liberate us from that really nasty inner voice telling us will never be good enough, we'll never succeed. So all of that and more in just a second. 2%.
很糟糕，而且你会失败，我认为对于某些人来说，这可以促使他们去表现，去做得更好，变得更好。但这并不是一种特别可持续的激励自己的方式，因为当我们失败时，我们只会强化那个信念系统；而当我们成功时，那只是运气。那个声音不会消失。这就是循环，对吧？这就像喝更多的酒却期望它能帮你戒酒一样。用自我批判来推动自己或消除消极的自我评价并不能让你更爱自己。休息之后，我想讨论我们对自己如此苛刻的另外两个原因，以及摆脱这种习惯、将我们从那个告诉我们永远不够优秀、永远不会成功的讨厌内心声音中解放出来的最佳方法。所以所有这些以及更多内容，马上回来。2%。
That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is a number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿，在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你最终就会还给世界一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TW0% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
收听《2%》。也就是“TW0%”。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍了拍小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以去寻找答案。在《回顾往昔》播客中。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。
Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近的一集，马克·拉蒙特·希尔大谈80年代的可卡因。需要澄清的是，84年对我意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊聊可卡因，但为了让你们知道我的意思。马克，这是我们第二期讨论可卡因了。所以我开始看出这里有一条主线。我们现在还讨论了艾滋病。谢谢你把话说完。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness, you know, your podcast, and your health awareness,
是的。我认为没有比这更重要的年份了，对于黑人来说。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。收听《回顾往昔》，在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难学习》，我是主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，你知道，你的播客，以及健康意识，
this month. I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
这个月。我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的有。特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们在追求某样东西时，我们太陷入追逐本身，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于赢和输。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地做一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《艰难学习》中，我们将就疗愈、成长、父职、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio App。搜索《艰难学习》并立即收听。
In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd, found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in silence, correct? I doctored the test once.
2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了长达数年的法律战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试，对吗？我只篡改了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been the same thing.
这需要一大批网络侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。
Greg, a lesbian, Michael Maranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
格雷格、一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的天呐。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to a love-trapped podcast on the I-Heart Radio app,
女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻：劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这还没结束。在iHeart Radio App收听《爱情陷阱》播客，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There are two final psychological explanations that I want to discuss super briefly. The first is overthinking and overanalyzing, and the second is the power of social comparison as a fuel for our inner critic. If you listened to my episode on overthinking,
Apple Podcasts，或你在哪里获取播客。最后有两个我想简短讨论的心理学解释。第一个是过度思考和过度分析，第二个是社会比较的力量，它成为了我们内心批判者的燃料。如果你听过我关于过度思考的那一集，
it's an absolute favorite of mine, you'll know that it's sometimes possible to almost be too self-aware. And one of the consequences of that is being way too hard on ourselves, especially in relation to how we think others perceive us. Our brain tricks us into thinking that overthinking a scenario, examining every possible way we've messed up or done something wrong, will prepare us for the future. It will allow us to prepare for the judgment of others. It links to this fear of uncertainty, firstly, but also, our innate evolutionary fear of the opinions of others.
那绝对是我的最爱，你就会知道，有时几乎可能做到过于自我觉察。而其中一个后果就是对自己过于苛刻，特别是关于我们认为别人是如何看待我们的。我们的大脑欺骗我们，让我们以为过度思考一个情境、审视我们搞砸或做错事的每一种可能方式，会为我们的未来做好准备。它将使我们能够为他人的评判做好准备。首先，这与对不确定性的恐惧有关，同时也与我们对他人意见的内在进化恐惧有关。
And I think that's really crucial. Others' opinions, they are important. Let's not discredit that entirely. Historically, we needed the approval of others to remain in the in-group to be accepted and therefore protected by the herd. And it's been proposed that our tendency for negative self-talk evolved from this instinct. This fascinating article, I'll leave it in the description. it's summed it up perfectly. Negative self-talk has served an evolutionary purpose. It comes from
我认为这真的很关键。别人的意见确实重要，我们不必完全否定它。在过去，我们需要获得别人的批准才能留在群体内被接纳，从而受到群体的保护。有人提出，我们倾向于进行负面自我对话就是从这种本能进化而来的。这篇精彩的文章，我会留在简介里，它总结得非常完美。负面自我对话曾起到过进化的作用。它来自
this evolutionary brain circuit in our brain. It's called the default mode network. And it helped people survive by aligning their interests with the group norms. We needed to follow the standards of the group. We need to constantly monitor our behavior so that if we step out of line, we can correct ourselves before we're ostracized. That is why the default mode is self-directed and critical. It's trying to keep you alive. There's also that element of social comparison. Our inner critic loves, absolutely loves using others as fuel for our own insecurities.
我们大脑中的这个进化脑回路，被称为默认模式网络。它通过将个人的利益与群体规范保持一致来帮助人类生存。我们需要遵循群体的标准。我们需要不断监督自己的行为，这样一旦我们出格，就能在被排挤之前纠正自己。这就是为什么默认模式是自我导向且充满批判性的。它是在试图让你活下去。其中还有社交比较的因素。我们的内在批判者非常、绝对非常喜欢利用别人作为我们自身不安全感的燃料。
How do I know that I'm a terrible person? Well, look at her. She's obviously incredible and kind, and since I'm not like her, I must be awful. How do I know I'm a failure? look at all that they've achieved. Look at them. How do I know that I'm unattractive? Well, she is beautiful. I don't look like her. So I must be unattractive. I must be ugly. I think that the important thing is to realize that the existence of someone else's value and success is not evidence of our inadequacy. Those two things are completely separate. Our value and their value
我怎么知道自己是个糟糕的人？你看她。她显然非常优秀、善良，既然我不像她，那我一定很糟糕。我怎么知道自己是个失败者？看看他们取得的所有成就。看看他们。我怎么知道自己没有吸引力？你看她多漂亮。我长得不像她。所以我一定没有吸引力，一定很丑。我认为重要的一点是要意识到，别人的价值和成功并不是我们无能的证据。这两件事是完全分开的。我们的价值和他们的价值
are not mutually exclusive. No one is living the same way. And beyond that, I think an important thing to remember is that no one is looking at you as closely or judging you as closely as you are judging yourself. Our inner critic benefits from us feeling like we're at the center of the universe. Because that just adds weight to how important our actions and behaviors are and therefore how perfect they need to be. that's not true no one is looking at you i promise we are all just as self-obsessed as the next person
并不是互不相容的。没有人是以同一种方式生活的。除此之外，我认为有一点很重要，那就是没有人像你审视自己那样密切地注视着你或评判你。我们的内在批判者让我们觉得自己是宇宙的中心，这让我们受益。因为这只会增加我们的行为有多重要、因而需要多么完美的份量。但事实并非如此，没有人看着你，我向来保证，我们所有人都和旁人一样自恋，
and there's this thought experiment i always like to do when i start to really worry and overthink about the opinions of others and that is when was the last time you noticed a mistake someone else made when was the last time that you cringed at someone else and what was that person's name. What were they wearing? What does that say about them? And how often do you actually think about it? Genuinely, how often? Because if you're thinking about someone else's mistakes a lot, that's really not their problem. That's a you problem. And the same goes for other people who are spending their hours judging you. That is not your problem. And exacerbating or heightening those opinions in your mind is only going to increase your susceptibility and I guess the frequency by which
每当我开始真正担心并过度思考别人的意见时，我总是喜欢做一个思想实验，那就是：你上一次注意到别人犯错误是什么时候？你上一次对别人感到尴尬是什么时候？那个人的名字叫什么？他们当时穿什么？这说明了他们什么？你实际上多久会想一次？真的，多久一次？因为如果你经常想起别人的错误，那真的不是他们的问题，那是你自己的问题。那些花时间评判你的其他人也是如此。那不是你的问题。在脑海中加剧或放大这些意见，只会增加你的易感性，我想也就是
you are hard on yourself. So how do we stop doing this? How do we rein in that pesky inner voice? That can feel especially hard. I want to give credit to people who are like, I don't know if I can do that because, you know, when we understand the childhood roots and the roots in so many historical events, childhood bullying, things that we cannot change, it's really hard to feel like we have agency or control over this thought pattern. But I do believe that we can change our negative self-perception. Those are our thoughts. We should feel empowered and able to control them. Additionally, I think when we think good things about ourselves, it kind of makes us this like amazing person. Like, I don't know if there is a theory behind this. Like, I haven't really
你对自己严厉的频率。那么我们该如何停止这样做？我们如何控制那个讨厌的内在声音？这可能会让人感觉格外困难。我想对那些说“我不知道我能不能做到”的人表示理解，因为你知道的，当我们了解到童年根源以及许多历史事件的根源、童年霸凌、我们无法改变的事情时，真的很难觉得自己对这种思维模式有代理权或控制力。但我确实相信我们可以改变我们的负面自我认知。那是我们的想法。我们应该感到自己有权力和能力去控制它们。此外，我认为当我们对自己的看法变好时，它会让我们变成一个如此了不起的人。就像，我不知道这背后的理论是什么。比如，我没有真正
looked into it. So take it with a grain of salt. But I think anecdotally, I've found that when I think better things about myself, I think better things about others. I just kind of have this, like, this glow, this energy to me that I find really attractive and that I would hope others do as well because you already see yourself in a better light. You feel more respect for yourself. And you demand that respect from others. So I do think, it's really critical that we step through exactly how we can stop judging ourselves, being mean to ourselves and putting ourselves down. I think our initial instinct when we initially recognize ourselves in a negative thought spiral
去深入研究过。所以大家听听就好，不必过于当真。但我凭经验发现，当我对自己有更好的看法时，我对别人的看法也会变好。我身上就会散发着一种光芒，一种我认为非常有吸引力的能量，我也希望别人会这么觉得，因为你已经以更好的眼光看待自己了。你会更尊重自己。并且你也会要求别人给予这种尊重。所以我确实认为，剖析我们究竟该如何停止评判自己、对自己刻薄以及贬低自己，是至关重要的。我认为当我们最初意识到自己陷入负面思维螺旋时，我们的第一直觉
is to ironically be more self-critical to shame ourselves. Criticizing our self-criticism comes from that misguided belief that you have to do something in response to it. And since we've formed a habit around judgment, our knee-jerk reaction to counteract the self-criticism is to just amp it up to just add more fuel to the fire. I think you can either treat your inner critic as an enemy, you can treat them as an ally, or as neither, as just a thing, it's just something that exists. And I think that taking away its power by detaching it from our identity, we regain the most
讽刺的是，往往是更加自我批判、羞辱自己。对自我批判进行批判，源于那种误解，即你必须对它做出某种回应。既然我们已经围绕判断养成了习惯，我们抵制自我批判的膝跳反应就是将其升级，给火上浇更多的油。我认为你可以把你的内在批判者当作敌人，可以把它当作盟友，或者两者都不是，只是一件东西，它只是某种存在的东西。我认为通过将其与我们的身份剥离来夺走它的力量，我们可以重新获得最大的
control. So you need to create kind of a psychological distance from your self-criticism by personifying it. Give it a name. Give it a feature. Give it a face. Maybe call it the little devil. It could be anything. Just give it a name. Treat it like it's neither an enemy or a friend. It's just this little creature that exists in your mind who wonders from room to room. You know, occasionally it pops up, but you know what's around and it's not scary and you can acknowledge it and say hi, be like, hi little creature, hi little devil, whatever you want to call it, and then ignore it. It's just like a little critter that lives in your house. This article in the Harvard Business Review, which is one of my go-to places for finding some of these studies, an amazing resource. If you are a psychology student, I will say,
控制权。所以你需要通过拟人化来与你的自我批判保持某种心理距离。给它起个名字。给它一个特征。给它一张脸。也许叫它小恶魔。什么都可以。只要给它起个名字。把它当作既不是敌人也不是朋友。它只是存在于你脑海中的一个小生物，在各个房间里闲逛。你知道，它偶尔会冒出来，但你知道它就在周围，它并不可怕，你可以承认它并打个招呼，比如，嗨，小生物，嗨，小恶魔，随便你想叫它什么，然后忽略它。它就像一只住在你家里的宠物。这篇《哈佛商业评论》上的文章，是我寻找其中一些研究的首选地方之一，是一个了不起的资源。如果你是一名心理学专业学生，我要说的是，
but it explains why this personification is so powerful. When we name our inner critic, This leverages a concept called cognitive diffusion, and it's a process by which we separate ourselves and our identity from our thoughts. So diffusion is shown to reduce discomfort. It reduces stress, reduces particularly stress around negative thoughts. And it also promotes psychological flexibility or the capacity to be aware and open and to adapt to your changing emotional circumstances. You know, it's not, your thoughts do not own you. That's what cognitive diffusion says. Your thoughts are just a thought. There's also this incredible theory in psychology called radical self-compassion. I could talk about this idea for hours. It's possibly my new favorite theory. And it initially arose as just radical compassion. And it was used to describe a specific type of empathy towards other people that this philosopher can,
但它解释了为什么这种拟人化如此强大。当我们给我们的内在批判者命名时，这就利用了一个叫做认知解离的概念，这是一个我们将自己和我们的身份与我们的想法分开的过程。因此解离已被证明可以减少不适。它能减轻压力，特别是减轻围绕消极想法的压力。它还能促进心理灵活性，即意识到、开放并适应不断变化的 તમારે 情绪环境的能力。你知道，这并不是说，你的想法不拥有你。这就是认知解离所说的。你的想法只是一种想法。心理学中还有一个令人难以置信的理论，叫做激进自我同情。我可以谈论这个想法几个小时。这可能是我现在最喜欢的理论。它最初作为激进同情心出现。它被用来描述对其他人的特定类型的同情，这位哲学家坚信，
hampert, he suggested that loving others unconditionally kind of has a healing element to it. When we love others deeply, we can heal them. We can alleviate what they're going through. And when we direct that compassion and love towards ourselves, we can heal ourselves and stop being so hard on ourselves. We do this by emulating the kind of love we would typically receive from others and giving that love to ourselves. redirecting it. We don't need to earn it. Our self-compassion is radical and freely given. Think about it in terms of the five love languages to kind of structure our thinking. So those are words of affirmation, quality time, receiving gifts, acts of service and physical touch.
汉珀特（Hampert）提出，无条件地爱他人具有一种治愈的成分。当我们深深地爱他人时，我们可以治愈他们。我们可以减轻他们正在经历的痛苦。当我们把这种同情和爱转向我们自己时，我们可以治愈自己，不再对自己那么苛刻。我们通过模仿通常从别人那里得到的这种爱，并把这种爱给予我们自己来做到这一点。重新引导它。我们不需要去赢得它。我们的自我同情是激进而无条件给予的。从五种语言的角度来考虑它，以便构建我们的思维。也就是肯定的话语、优质的陪伴、接受礼物、服务的行动和身体接触。
You need to adapt and adopt those love languages and direct them towards yourself. Speak kind words. Say two things to yourself every day that are positive. tell yourself that you are proud of how far you've come. Tell others that you are proud of yourself. As you would say that you are proud of your friends or your family members. I would also say, make time to spend with your thoughts. My favorite activity is solo dates and one of my friends, Claude, who was on the show recently, shared this amazing practice that they have where once a month they go to a different Italian restaurant in Sydney and get a glass of wine, a pastor and they journal about how they're feeling and where they see the next month going.
你需要适应并采纳这些爱的语言，并将它们导向你自己。说善良的话。每天对自己说两件积极的事情。告诉自己你为你所走过的路程感到骄傲。告诉别人你为你自己感到骄傲。就像你会说你为你的朋友或家人感到骄傲一样。我还要说，腾出时间与你的想法相处。我最喜欢的活动是独处约会，我的朋友克劳德（Claude）最近上了节目，分享了一个他们一直在做的了不起的做法，那就是他们每个月去悉尼的一家不同的意大利餐厅，喝一杯酒，吃一份意面，并写日记记录他们的感受以及他们认为下个月会怎样。
That is self-love. That is self-compassion and it counteracts that negative self-image. You know, let's adapt those further. Buy yourself a little trait every now and again. Not because you've worked hard for it, not because you've been quote unquote good, but because you deserve to have nice things. You deserve to feel happy. make your bed in the morning, clean your room in the evening, because you know that your future self will thank you. The same way that you would want others to do upon you with acts of service, you can do upon to yourself. And finally, give yourself physical touch. This sounds really strange sometimes when I explain it to people, but touch actually activates our parasympathetic nervous system.
这就是自爱。这就是自我同情，它能抵消负面的自我形象。你知道，让我们进一步调整这些做法。偶尔给自己买点小恩惠。不是因为你努力工作了，不是因为你表现得“好”，而是因为你值得拥有美好的事物。你值得感到快乐。早上整理床铺，晚上打扫房间，因为你知道未来的你会感谢你。就像你希望别人对你行使服务的行动一样，你也可以对自己这样做。最后，给予自己身体接触。当我向人们解释这一点时，有时听起来真的很奇怪，但接触实际上会激活我们的副交感神经系统。
That is what helps us exit flight or flight mode. and it helps us feel safe and calm. And we can physically self-sove and create that same reaction by doing things like placing one hand over our heart and the other hand over our shoulder and just giving a tight squeeze or caressing our own face. That is radical self-compassion. It's saying you don't need to earn the love that you give yourself.
这就是帮助我们摆脱战斗或逃跑模式的原因。它能帮助我们感到安全和平静。我们可以通过做一些事情来在生理上自我安慰并产生相同的反应，比如把一只手放在心口上，另一只手放在肩膀上，然后紧紧地拥抱一下或抚摸自己的脸。这就是激进的自我同情。它是在说，你不需要去赢得你给予自己的爱。
It is freely given. It is yours. If you don't see how this relates to minimizing your inner critic, I want to explain a little bit further. we know that one of the root causes of being hard on ourselves is feeling like you are undeserving of love or empathy or seeking validation from others because you know you're of childhood deprivation or an intense pressure to prove yourself or bullying but when you institute radical self-compassion you give yourself the permission that maybe others haven't given you to feel good to celebrate yourself to be loved. And before we ask others to do that for us, we need to find a way to reach that
它是无条件给予的。它是你的。如果你不明白这与尽量减少你的内在批判者有什么关系，我想进一步解释一下。我们知道，对自我苛刻的根源之一是觉得你不配得到爱或同情，或者从别人那里寻求验证，因为你知道你经历了童年剥夺、证明自己的巨大压力或霸凌，但当你实行激进的自我同情时，你给了自己别人可能没有给过你的允许，去感觉良好，去庆祝自己，去被爱。在我们要求别人为我们这样做之前，我们需要找到一种方法来得出这个结论，
conclusion and deliver that feeling on an individual level. And there have been so many experiments that have shown self-compassion reduces the negative effects of shame and self-criticism. And it's even created its own type of therapeutic practice called compassion-focused therapy. So there you go. Look into that as well. I find. that is so fascinating. Some other strategies are to do a bit of a mental and social detox. Sometimes it's the things in our environment that are causing us to be excessively negative. Maybe a particularly strained toxic friendship or a bad habit that is bringing forward a lot of guilt. So do a bit of a stock of your life. What feels good? What doesn't? What is creating a negative
并在个人层面上传递这种感觉。有那么多的实验表明，自我同情可以减少羞耻感和自我批判的负面影响。它甚至催生了一种自己的治疗实践，叫做以同情为焦点的疗法。所以你看。也可以去了解一下。我发现这太迷人了。其他一些策略是进行一点心理和社交排解。有时正是我们环境中的事情导致我们变得过度消极。也许是一段特别紧张、有毒的友谊，或者是一个带来很多内疚的坏习惯。所以对你的生活进行一番盘点。什么感觉好？什么不好？是什么在产生负面的
thought spiral and is it possible to eliminate this from your life? One of the things that my therapist actually said to me as well is like, what, and what days do you feel the best about yourself? And what are you doing on those days? What are you wearing on those days? And on what days are you feeling bad about yourself? What do you do on those days? What are you wearing? Who are you interacting with? What are you eating? All of those little things really do contribute to our self-image on a day-to-day basis. Also, further to that idea kind of of not treating self-criticism like an enemy, another way to bring it under our control is to almost counterintuitively give ourselves the occasional permission to be a bit mean. You can't always quit cold turkey, especially if that negative self-talk is a deeply ingrained
思维螺旋，是否有可能将其从你的生活中消除？我的治疗师实际上对我说过的一件事也是，什么，你在哪些日子里对自己的感觉最好？你在那些日子里在做什么？你在那些日子里穿什么？你在哪些日子里对自己的感觉不好？你在那些日子里做什么？你在穿什么？你在和谁互动？你在吃什么？所有这些小事情确实都在日常基础上对我们的自我形象产生了影响。此外，进一步延伸那种不把自我批判当作敌人的想法，将它置于我们控制之下的另一种方法，几乎是反直觉地偶尔允许自己刻薄一点。你不能总是突然彻底戒掉，特别是如果那种负面自我对话是一种根深蒂固的
thought pattern. So instead, give yourself five minutes a day to think those negative thoughts if you really can't break out of them. Contain the habit. And then you can be like, okay, I gave myself five minutes. I did that. I let myself feel bad. I let myself be cruel. And that part of my day is done. Those thoughts are going to remain in that moment and my life is going to go on. It's also important to just be neutral towards your thoughts, especially as they relate to your perceived failures or imperfections. A thought is just a thought. It's not the truth. You can think it and you don't have to believe it. It can just exist. That was a really powerful realization for me, not just in relation to my tendency to be hard on myself, but also how I treat self-doubt and anxiety and even body dysmorphia
思维模式。所以相反，如果你真的无法摆脱那些消极的想法，每天给自己五分钟去思考它们。控制这个习惯。然后你可以说，好吧，我给了自己五分钟。我做到了。我让自己感觉不好。我让自己变得残酷。我一天的那个部分已经结束了。那些想法将留在那个时刻，我的生活将继续下去。对你的想法保持中立也很重要，特别是当它们与你感知到的失败或不完美有关时。一个想法只是一个想法。它不是真相。你可以这样想，而不必相信它。它只是可以存在。对我来说，这是一个非常深刻的认识，不仅与我对自己严厉的倾向有关，还与我如何对待自我怀疑、焦虑甚至身体畸形恐惧症
and insecurity. Just because I think something about myself does not make it true. And I think all of those practices are incredibly liberating. We deserve to have a peaceful mind. I think we can be our own worst enemy. We can really take on the feedback of others and make it our own and criticize as a way to almost protect ourselves, but also to humble ourselves and to make ourselves feel less than. You are not the only one, I promise, I think that this is highly common in this generation, especially because we have so many points to elicit social comparison. Like I talk about the prominence of social media all the time, but, you know, it used to be that we could only really view those in our community and in our surroundings. And then we had the internet, but it was always in one corner of the house on the
和不安全感有关。仅仅因为我对自己的某种想法并不意味着它是真的。我认为所有这些做法都非常具有解放意义。我们应该拥有一个平静的头脑。我认为我们可能是自己最大的敌人。我们真的可以接受别人的反馈并把它变成我们自己的反馈，把批判当作一种几乎是为了保护我们自己，但也是为了让自己谦卑，让我们觉得自己不如人。我向来保证，你不是唯一的一个，我认为这在这代人中非常普遍，特别是因为我们有太多的点来引发社会比较。就像我一直谈论社交媒体的显赫地位一样，但是，你知道，过去我们真的只能看到我们社区和周围的人。然后我们有了互联网，但它总是放在家里的某个角落
computer. And now suddenly, we can walk around every day with a phone glued to our hands. And if at any point, we want to feel bad, we want to judge ourselves, we can find a million ways to do that. We can look at a million different pictures of other people's perfect lives and perfect bodies and perfect jobs and just feel inherently really crappy. So I don't think that that is forever. I think that's something that we can act out against and we can push back against. And I just hope that this episode gave you some valuable insight, firstly, in psychoeducation, but also some tips and some strategies.
电脑上。而现在突然之间，我们可以每天拿着粘在手上的手机到处走。如果在任何时候，我们想感觉不好，我们想评判自己，我们都可以找到一百万种方法来做到这一点。我们可以看一百万张关于别人完美生活、完美身体和完美工作的照片，然后内心感觉真的很糟糕。所以我不认为这会永远持续下去。我认为这是我们可以采取行动并进行反击的事情。我只希望这一集能为你提供一些有价值的见解，首先是心理教育，还有一些小贴士和策略。
Like I said, radical self-compassion, life-changing. So life-changing. Cognitive diffusion, also incredible. So this episode was definitely one that I really enjoyed researching and putting together. As always, if you enjoyed it and you think someone in your life might enjoy it as well, please feel free to send them a link to this episode. You never know what they'll take from it. Also, again, I'm going to plug the Patreon because I would love to see more of my loyal listeners over there.
就像我说的，激进的自我同情，能够改变生活。太能改变生活了。认知解离，也令人难以置信。所以这一集绝对是我非常喜欢研究和制作的一集。像往常一样，如果你喜欢它，并且认为你生活中的某个人也可能会喜欢它，请随时将这集的链接发送给他们。你永远不知道他们会从中吸取什么。另外，我还是要宣传一下Patreon，因为我很想在那里看到更多我忠实的听众。
You get access to, you know, bonus episodes, bonus content and newsletter, all of the episode transcripts. You can vote on upcoming episodes, free merch, and it's as little as $1 a month. So it goes a long way when a lot of people contribute. I'll leave a link in the episode description. And please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple, Spotify, wherever you're listening right now. If you did enjoy this episode, we will be back next week. I will see you then. Hey, what's good, y'all?
你可以访问，你知道的，奖励剧集、奖励内容和时事通讯，以及所有的剧集文字稿。你可以对即将到来的剧集进行投票，获得免费周边，而且每月只需1美元起。所以当很多人贡献时，它会大有帮助。我会在剧集简介中留下一个链接。如果你真的喜欢这一集，请随时在Apple、Spotify或你现在正在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。如果你确实喜欢这一集，我们下周会回来。到时候见。嘿，最近怎么样，伙计们？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
欢迎收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都真的不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士在进行这些对话。
How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, wherever you get your podcast.
有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHeart广播应用程序、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast.
2%。这就是在也有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中心理坚韧、健身和建立韧性的科学。经历一些困难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是数字的TWO%在IHeart广播应用程序、Apple Podcast上。
or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
或者在你获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约好过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。
On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. on the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
在IHeart广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get Your podcasts. This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代一样。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为没有比这更重要的一年了，对黑人来说。在IHeart广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。这是一个I-Heart播客。保证是人类制作的。这一集还没有评论。点击文字稿中的任何句子来留下评论。